j'ai décidé de
faire une randonnée en plastique
pour souligner que
nous devons changer le monde
[Music]
voyageur
donc je suis un biologiste moléculaire j'ai
étudié en allemagne et j'ai décidé de venir
au portugal j'aime ce pays et puis
je suis devenu un  consultant médical également ici
à lisbonne et toutes les trois minutes, je
prenais essentiellement ma planche de surf et oui, j'ai
apprécié
le magnifique littoral du portugal.
J'étais toujours essentiellement entouré de déchets
par du plastique et donc j'ai dit que ce
n'était plus possible au début.
mon utilisation du plastique,
fondamentalement, comme le lien avec la nature,
euh, m'a vraiment fait réfléchir à
la gravité de ce problème de pollution et
j'ai donc décidé d'accord, cela
doit changer, être dans un bureau consulter des
médecins est très très important, mais
ce n'était pas mon épanouissement  plus j'ai quitté
mon travail alors j'ai commencé à voyager
avec ma camionnette de plage en plage au
portugal en ramassant les ordures de tous les jours et en
composant à propos de ces ordures aussi un  chanson
avec mon ukulélé et donc après 160 jours
d'affilée,
j'avais 160 vidéos et 160 chansons
[Musique]
et j'étais fondamentalement ouais pris dans ma
bulle instagram
et j'atteignais ces personnes qui sont
déjà au courant de la recherche
du hashtag recycle ou hashtag  nettoyer les
plages et donc j'ai décidé de faire quelque chose d'
extraordinaire je suis entré dans le réseau des
ong et écologistes ici au
portugal pour sensibiliser ensemble à
travailler sur le problème de la pollution plastique
ensemble et plus seul sur instagram
j'ai décidé de
je vais sur un  randonnée en plastique
pour souligner que
nous devons changer la
[musique]
58 jours, j'ai parcouru toutes les côtes
chaque mètre et j'ai rencontré plus de 100
initiatives d'ONG et d'écologistes
ici au Portugal, c'est très très
impressionnant le nombre de personnes que nous avons qui se
soucient de nous avons maintenant un  film documentaire
de 90 minutes reflétant toutes ces ong
ici au portugal en même temps, tous
les déchets collectés l'année dernière lors de la
randonnée en plastique ont été convertis en art et
maintenant nous  avons 27 artistes ou personnes
créatives ici au portugal et nous avons 27
œuvres d'art à partir de déchets installées sur
toute la côte portugaise
je suis un allemand
je suis ici au portugal pas parce que je
veux sensibiliser et le problème est ici
plus critique que partout ailleurs dans
le monde, c'est comme un
problème mondial, peu importe où
vous êtes, vous pouvez commencer à essayer de parler à
tout le monde et c'est un problème pour
tout le monde, essentiellement
ce que j'entends par exemple en tant que voix en
Allemagne  assez souvent ouais c'est
bien que tu fasses ça au portugal
parce que tu es si près de l'océan
cependant nous devons comprendre que les
déchets que nous produisons vont dans une poubelle mais
ce qui se passe après ce n'est pas ce que
nous
voyons  il y a trop de plastique là-bas,
tout le plastique se décompose en microplastique
et le microplastique en est fondamentalement
la partie écrasante parce que
si vous allez à la plage et que je vous mets au défi,
allez tous à la plage une fois, pas seulement en
profitant  c'est juste pour voir ce qu'il
y a là-bas et ce microplastique me rend triste
parce qu'il n'est pas possible de nettoyer et
je dis toujours ouais nettoyons la
plage mais
il ne s'agit pas de
nettoyer s'il vous plaît refusez de chanter une utilisation pour
le bien de l'océan ouais
c'est  pas à propos du
nettoyage, nous devons arrêter le
mouvement des plastiques dans l'océan